sinon à nous pencher sur le futur man
notre région de consultation est en
cours et nous y contribuons avec karine
patouillet fondatrice d'une agence de
communication a dit jean pierre bodineau
ancien président du cesr de bourgogne
robert chapuis professeur de géographie
à l'université de dijon et vincent petit
auteur de comment peut-on encore être
franchies et en première partie il
semblait qui se dégage un consensus sur
ce plateau autour de bourgogne franche
comté
je vous livre la réaction de magali qui
nous dit pas d'accord que c'est laid
bourgogne franche comté
bonjour l'originalité et elle nous
propose du coup le comté de bourgogne où
la comté de bourgogne qui serait selon
elle plus judicieux qui veut réagir
alors bolets c'est très subjectif force
à la comté de bourgogne ça ne règle pas
le problème puisque c'est une petite
partie de la grande région donc
légitimement il ya une partie de la
région qui peut ne pas se sentir
concerné quant à la nouveauté
on est tributaire de notre histoire et
c'est notre histoire qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on pose le problème en
termes de bourgogne franche comté
ça pourrait être autrement mais nous
avons vécu ensemble je t'aime moi non
plus acceptez vous avez dit niant tout
début d'émission l'idéal ce serait les
bourgogne où la grande bourgogne parce
que c'est pas seulement la ponte ben oui
ça aurait pu être les de bourgogne la
grande bourgogne
mais encore une fois je pense que les
comtois ne se retrouverait pas donc
c'est une histoire de suisse est
habilité aussi d'attachement environ
sajoo et puis aussi on doit tenir compte
de la notoriété comme l'a dit mon
atelier 2
le document existait ou n'en avoir que
l'impression au moins en moins dans le
nom existe et aléas normaux le nom
disparaît on a un peu l'impression que
la région disparaît également oui mais
on peut vous rétorquer que par exemple
le pays basque à une très forte identité
continuer à exister les en sont fiers de
cette identité de territoire et ce n'est
ni le nom d'un département ni le nom
d'une région le nom d'une collectivité
ce ça renvoie pas forcément à la réalité
du terrain mais notre rôle quand et va
continuer d'exister pays basque est
encore une fois une réalité qui est vécu
et la franche comté est une réalité
vécue par les habitants
la bourgogne est vécue par les habitants
à passer au moment où vous avez
effectivement des réalités locales
régionales qui sont vécus comme tel il
ya sans doute effectivement des idées on
est sûr c'est que ce type là on en a pas
ici n'ont pas vraiment pas on a pas on
n'a pas d'équivalent au pays basque en
bourgogne franche comté et encore une
fois on parlait tout à l'heure dans soif
un lien interactif dit effectivement on
confirme que je pense essayer de créer
des emplois l'emploi c'est
l'attractivité la facilité elle se
travaille aussi à partir d'une
visibilité et d'un an donc à passer un
moment on va gommer une des deux régions
on va avoir un problème d'attractivité
aussi on parle depuis le début de
bourgogne franche comté
ça implique systématiquement pour les
franc comtois lettres en deuxième
position derrière le mot bourgogne
puisque on pose toutes les questions à
la goyave ailleurs un débat interactif
les constats d'un côté un peu de vécu
par les comtois comme le fait de d'être
systématiquement renvoyés à l'image de
la région qui est plus petit dans l'es2
dû perdre parce que c'est ce qu'on
entend dans la fusion il ya quand même
une réalité
la bourgogne est plus peuplée dijon et
et sans doute plus dynamique que
besançon donc je pense une réalité que
que les francs comtois ont accepté mais
le débat me semble intéressant parce
qu'en fait on parle de fusion mais on
devrait plutôt parler de mariage et dans
le mariage et bien les deux mariés à
porte de leur patronyme est bien qu'on
accole et on va pas demander à l'épousé
de renoncer à son patronyme longtemps
demandé maintenant la loi permet à
l'époux zhu l'époux de prendre les 2 et
de garder les patronymes cette réunion
un fusion
je crois que ce raid est plus équilibrée
entre recherche bourgogne franche comté
cbc je suis désolé il ya michel vauzelle
qui est l'ancien président de paca
provence alpes côte d'azur qui disait
récemment dans la presse que ç'avait été
horrible d'avoir choisi paca puisque
paca personne ne connaissait alors qu'il
y avait une très forte de nos de
notoriété à la fois de provence et de
côte d'azur est-ce qu'il faut tout faire
pour éviter de transformer vos gains de
franche comté en vf c'est lui moi je le
crois je dirais pas tout à fait franche
comté bourgogne mire est aussi bien je
sais pas si ça sera bien qu'il a
proposées en franche-comté pourquoi pas
franche comté de bourgogne
oui bon on a des habitudes je crois mais
je vous avais le raccourci surtout aux
journalistes de faire attention et de la
récession la monta au métal
mon exemple pas servir à grand chose si
ce n'est que quand vous allez
conceptualiser un logo évidemment vous
allez mettre les premières lettres les
trois premières lettres plus en avant
que le reste parce que c'est des
manuscrits l'excellent logique
encore une fois après on va pouvoir s'en
servir parce qu'aujourd'hui le support
numérique la communication numérique est
aussi importante à il faut dire que la
france est en tout cas est l'acronyme je
pense en parler de twitter tout à
l'heure mais par exemple il faut aussi
prendre en compte ces réalités là c'est
pas prioritaire comment on va faire
vivre c'est de la commune est
effectivement un hashtag plus court que
bourgogne franche comté ça sera aussi
beaucoup de filles simples à valoriser
mais pour moi ça va pas c'est pas c'est
pas le coeur de la discussion
est ce qu'il faut et ce qu'il faut
garder franche est ce que je vous
raconte et se ferait pas les de ramasser
le terme dont on dit qu'ils avaient un
coup de fil on nous propose aussi
franche bourgogne mais alors là du
conseil
je sens voilà mais bon bien de compter
par exemple ça marcherait ça fait quand
même un peu menu apéritif ses fictions
la coupe larry la contemple la
complémentarité entre 1,20 et un fromage
mais le mot franche et quand même joli
enfin c'est quand même pour parler très
vulgairement ça a de la gueule donc
c'est vrai que cet adjectif là à titre
personnel celles ci ont dépeint comme le
représentant sur ce plateau de l'iran de
gigantisme franc comtois adjectif
franche comté c'est très bien oui il
faut la gagner important que le nombre
me paraîtrait être une devise on je
souhaite très très intéressé par les
différentes formules qu'on peut trouver
pour caractériser la nouvelle région et
alors vous avez désigné par ça ne vient
pas spontanément à l'esprit je ne
proposerai temps mais je le fais en
forme de boutade une région où on
vieillit heureux parce que
malheureusement nous sommes une région
très très âgées qui va continuer de le
devenir alors ça après tout ça peut être
un slogan ça peut être une manière de
faire venir des tas de gens défaire
rester parce que notre problème
principal c'est l'attractivité quand
même
mais c'est quand même pas très porteur
pour l'avenir ça va être plus important
car elle va être très importante
effectivement le travail sur les valeurs
c'est là qu'on va travailler sur
l'identité pour savoir quels mots
choisis
ça risque d'ailleurs d'être un tout
petit peu compliqué c'est pour ça qu'on
repasse et qui vont se pense sa muse et
à essayer de trouver des choses ici
parce qu'il va falloir trouver un
équilibre entre les différentes voilà
une séance à tous qu'on veut valoriser
aussi encore une fois simplement de
cession mais quand même à
l'international
parce que je pense qu'on a des choses à
l'essai et que si on se trompe dans la
manière dont sont des signes identités
régionales parce que c'est à savent que
va servir slogan la baseline comme on
voudra il va vraiment falloir la choisir
en choisissant les mots est à mon avis
plus qu'une phrase il va falloir aussi
travaillé sur les termes qu'on veut
porter et sur la manière dont on va les
exprimer dont la déclinaison et je pense
que c'est beaucoup plus sans doute
beaucoup de porteurs de réfléchir sur ce
volet là que dans le gers un nouveau nom
visionneront alors je m'emballe des
révolutionnaires de nos montagnes ou non
de rivière somme au vaudou toutes ces
choses là on oublie leur addition
non il n'y a pas vraiment d'enthousiasmé
caire ça serait comme une armée où les
ex et la saône et un joli trait d'union
entre les deux régions à 7 après d'union
même si ça a été longtemps une frontière
et et même du tour de la frontière il y
avait des tas de gens qui vivaient de la
contrebande
c'est en permanence du sel notamment
vous n'avez qu'à une patrouille
al'avantage d'avoir bourgogne
franchement plus c'est que ça risque de
nous inquiéter des horreurs oui ça
risque fortement de taille quand on
regarde un peu ce qui se passe dans
d'autres régions y ont effectivement
certaines raisons beaucoup moins de sens
que nous je pense dans les mariages
blancs mais les régions où il ya
plusieurs effectivement un des exemples
où ça va être compliqué de garder un
bout d'identité régionale du dedans tout
cas de chacune des ses membres par
exemple il ya cette région là qui est la
région alsace jean rède ardennes et
justement dans ces régions là et c'est
pareil pour le sud-ouest puisqu'on
finalement quand c'est compliqué on
revient sur la géographie pur sud ouest
grand test je vous parle il s'empresse
de tout à l'heure du café nationale
parce que je suis doit est c'est valable
par rapport à paris par rapport à
barcelone se nomme les sens une
invention complète
nous on s'amuse et un petit peu surtout
jérémy inventé pour conter en prétendant
que c'est édifiant bourg comté ou france
bourgogne
oui non non il faut pas être original en
fait regardez il ya le poids de
l'histoire
non je n'ai
la franche comté c'est la cité romaine
la civitas romaine c'est à peu près le
même les mêmes frontières entre
guillemets les mêmes limites nous je
trouve très dommage de sacrifier tout ça
un mot sur vous par l'aide
internationale
on sait qu'on a eu on a dit aussi ont
fait ces grandes régions parce qu'il
faut qu'elle faisait un poids une taille
une identité aussi est ce que une région
bourgogne franche comté ce qu' elle
s'appelle bourgogne franche comté de
votre point de vue et elle est une c'est
une région vendable intéressante à
l'échelle de l'europe quand on va dire
catalogne quand on va dire oui
évidemment évidemment elle est déjà l ai
déjà vendable et déjà fondu en larmes et
les invendus
s'il n'y avait qu'un succès relatif par
rapport on est quand même coincé entre
les maisons par les deux métropoles
entre paris lyon et strasbourg
on avait déjà comme n'est pas coincée
si vous regardez bien les choses on est
aussi on aussi une région qui peut
gagner en attractivité de passage entre
guillemets c'est aussi des atouts qu'il
faut savoir valoriser tout sujet c'est
comment on parle de nous demain et c'est
vraiment plus il faut pas regarder
derrière ont regardé sans arrêt
j'ai l'impression que re4 aime beaucoup
les les contraintes rond nara en tout
cas et les points faibles qu'on peut
avoir
le fait qu'on soit effectivement la
petite fusion de france en primaire
c'est aussi un atout pour travailler en
termes d'exemplarité
on peut montrer les choses on peut aller
plus vite sur certains aspects peu le
peuvent certes un gros paquebot qu'on
vend beaucoup de mal à bouger sauf quand
vous fusionnez quand même les choses au
hcc
c'est très lourd donc je pense qu'on
peut justement être moteur montrer en
quoi cette identité régionale regroupe
et peut être vraiment porteuse ya
l'histoire racontée et d'essayer les
sodas faire vraiment finalement on
apprend de l'innovation pour cette
grande région c'est l'ouverture la
bourgogne avait beaucoup de qualités
mais n'était pas frontalière avec la
franche comté le devient mais j'ai été
beaucoup surpris moi par la réaction de
nos amis de rhénanie palatinat avec
lesquels la bourgogne est jumelée depuis
très longtemps qui m'a dit mais qu'elle
dix des douze semaines parce que c'est
que la franche comté et il va falloir
non mail la bourgogne
il ya une relation historique depuis
depuis 60 ans et donc ça leur paraît
c'est extraordinaire qu'on puisse comme
ça modifier la géographie politique or
quelques en quelques textes et j'aurais
libère enfin leur apprendre à connaître
la franche comté la franche comté elle
n'avait aucune relation avec l'allemagne
par contre elle a une relation avec les
communautés de la suisse on arrive
quasiment la fin de l'émission est une
question qui me semblent importantes
comment s'appelleront les habitants de
cette belle région c'est en bourgogne
secondaire est question d pour comtois
débours ni des francs bourguignons mais
vous avez déjà possession je parie que
les actuels bourrignon aux côtés du roi
françois resteront franc comtois tout en
habitant entre guillemets dans la même
maison administrativement il ya un
attachement identitaire très forte
on en sait encore ce qu'on parle de
grandes régions mais continue et on
risque de continuer à se déterminer en
sont des régions d'origine quelques
lignes l et quelques livres
la confusion des territoires de monsieur
bug godinot bourgogne franche comté
soeur rival ça c'est robert chapuis et
puis comment peut-on encore être franc
comtois c'est vincent petit qui était
donc tous les trois sur ce plateau à
khartoum avec un agent de 24 à dijon et
à paris merci à tous les cas pas d'être
venu essayer d'aider les bourguignons
les francs comtois se faire un avis dans
cette grande consultation rappelons que
vous pouvez donner votre avis sur le
site internet de la région jusqu'au 13
mars ont prouvé aussi l'envoyer par la
poste et on se retrouve samedi prochain
en bourgogne et en franche comté pour
les numéros de la voie est libre
merci bon week-end au revoir